we need the latest what's happening now
well I can't tell you exactly but
there's gonna be something that is going
to be announced pretty soon and I'm
probably gonna get told off for even
saying that well it better not be
tomorrow Mel B it's going to be a
project that we're very excited about so
are we gonna bring Victoria into them oh
yeah it's all five of us is it going to
be a full-fledged tour it'll be a
full-on fight I'm joking
[Music]
yeah I love seeing the gals reunite for
Jerry's 50th birthday oh yeah because I
was working but I wish you a happy
birthday and she's at least 75 now
so she's fine she's preserved herself
quite well well melby's 23 year old Mini
Me daughter Phoenix is paying homage to
her Timeless Spice Girl style in this
fun photo shoot today we're shooting me
as Mel B Phoenix
fashion I know I mean the good thing is
I've kept all my old clothes and they
still fit just about so I'm like oh so
you want to wear that and look like me
you look actually better than me no
y'all both are rocking them so well but
is there one outfit in particular rear
like Phoenix that is off limits mama uh
no because what I did with my style
because I used to style ourselves I used
to mix like
prop I mean I might want to be a little
tank top was one pound 99 but then my
bottoms were like a lot yeah so I like
to mix my next time yeah yeah yeah so I
mean Phoenix can wear it as long as she
doesn't like destroy it oh it's
disappeared forever into her closet
knows nothing if not brutally honest she
got candid with me about her painful
past where she alleges abuse which is
one reason she pushed herself to the
limits and joined Fox's Wednesday night
reality show special forces world's
toughest test I'm a Spice Girl I come
from build power that was girl powerless
nobody knew about it because I was very
ashamed and we don't talk about abuse
enough I was in a really horrendous
abusive relationship abuse especially
the amount of boost that I went through
you kind of have to really piece
yourself back together because you are
left broken fix your problem
everything was a trigger for me from
being yelled at from being
um beaten up this was me deciding to do
it for my reasons for myself to show
that you can come out of it the other
side I'm out I'm done I was surprised
that you threw in the town do you regret
looking back do you regret leaving when
you did this is all about testing my
fears and my limits after three days I
was like okay I'm exhausted now okay
with so much strength okay so do you
feel like you've taken tools I walked
away from there like I could conquer the
world I felt like Goliath
tell me this of the Spice Girls Who do
you think would fare well in this kind
of setting oh my God I actually don't
know because you have to go into a
certain Zone in this show
where you've probably never had to tap
into it before because who's who who
wakes up and goes okay I'm gonna drown
myself in the car today or I'm gonna do
an obstacle course and I actually
dislocated my knee on one of the optical
glitches and I whacked it back in and I
carried on running I was like you got it
girl you can feel the pain I'm badass I
was like oh wow that just happened but
I'm carrying on you have to tap into
something that that is so rare and raw
you don't even know it's there until
it's there so I would like to think
they'd all do really well
foreign